when you were growing up how many people
around you had a passion for filmmaking
my dad was definitely a film lover
for sure his favorite was fellini
he loved fellini and so he instilled
that that
love of fellini which then for me
branched off into
a love of fine arts of theater
and then and also film and my mother
also
she loves to watch film so does my
sister but i think it was definitely
my dad's you know love of fellini that
kind of
started everything else and you grew up
where
i grew up in portugal specifically
lisbon
and that's the capital it's all right oh
okay but then you
you went to school when did you decide
you were going to leave
portugal so i decided i was going to
leave when i applied for
art school in london
and i went to the slade school of fine
art which is part of university
college london oh wow so that's when i
started my undergraduate degree in fine
art media which was basically more
kind of video art performance art sound
as well so it was mainly kind of um
video installations was kind of what i
was doing most
of all and when you talk with the other
students there
were they also fellini lovers did they
remember
those films or because they were from
all over they chose
different directors i mean they they
were from
all over but i think that
you can say for most video artists at
least the ones that i met
that even if they weren't making
commercial film
that they were still very aware of
cinema and to a certain extent
like loved all the aspects of it i mean
and there were even some students that
did incorporate
actual clips from films in their work
but then kind of you know remixing them
you know deconstructing them in kind of
more experimental
ways i remember there was like one one
graduate student who
he took a clip from taxi driver
and he he he kind of he extended it
out so that there's this you know 360
degrees
shot that he just just kept going
forever
he was and that was that was the video
installation yeah interesting so
it was always present the world of film
was always present even in the
experimental
world and when you would watch these
fellini movies with your father
was it almost like film theory or you
were just watching it for sheer
enjoyment you weren't analyzing it or
i mean i was definitely watching it for
for the enjoyment
for sure and especially like americorps
i think
you know really kind of strikes a note
with that older mediterranean
generation because there's so much
crossover with like you know catholicism
and the church but then you know
burgeoning um
teenage sexuality and then how that
plays out
and i think that i only really started
to look at fellini's work theoretically
when i was in art school and i had to
write a dissertation
about um his work and how and then tying
that in with um
jungian archetypes oh wow which is kind
of
a lot of his films kind of lend
themselves to those kind
of readings because he he plays so much
with the female archetype with the
with the anima interesting and so
what was the do you remember the exact
title of your of your dissertation
i think it was like an exploration of
feminine archetypes
in the film of in the films of fellini i
think
something along those lines yeah and
just one
one last question what what archetype
did he
tend to to go with most or was there not
one that he went with
i think that it was i mean definitely
the
the madonna you know the
that archetype that exists in a lot of
you know catholic cultures mediterranean
cultures
the the virgin mother but then kind of
juxtaposing
that archetype with the more you know
the
of babylon like kind of the two
sides of the same
coin but two archetypes that seem to be
very present
in the male psyche especially in
in in the mediterranean sure
oh fascinating yeah have you always been
the one who's like to tell stories
around you
especially growing up i have to say i
think that i was more
the one who likes to listen to stories
um i think maybe maybe i think
i think because i started off acting
actually like when i was a teenager
and that was probably for me to kind of
get out of my shell
a bit more because i was a bit quiet and
i was a bit withdrawn
and i think as as an actor you know when
you're on when you're on stage or when
you're in front of a camera you're the
one
telling a story you know with your body
with your voice um so i kind of
i did that for a bit but then i think
i had the desire to
tell my stories but then to collaborate
with actors for them to actually embody
those those stories but to answer your
question i think i
i love i loved reading growing up and i
loved just
just listening to any anecdote any story
you know i would always
with with my girlfriends or with my
friends it was always you know
tell me what you did for your weekend i
want to know everything like
that was i was more the one who absorbed
the narratives around me
and actually you know talked about what
i did for my weekend
and how did you know you'd be good with
a camera
well i think i only really started
working with cameras when i went to art
school and i was doing video art so like
i had my own camera and i was making my
own little
experimental films so that's that's when
i really learned like the ins and outs
of
um of a video camera um and then when
i left art school i had a lot of friends
who worked in tv and media production
and they were the ones who said
you know why don't you apply for camera
assistant jobs because you know you seem
to have a lot of technical practical
knowledge
and that's that's how that started and
and now i can say i know my way around
more
more high-end cameras than back in the
day
would you say filmmaking has always been
easy for you i think
writing comes easier
but then filmmaking because there is
also
all the practical aspects
you know like funding getting a crew
together getting a producer i mean
that's
that's always each film presents its own
challenges so i don't want to say
that oh it's so it's always easy to make
a film it's always easy to make a film
because it's you have to you know get
that boulder up
over the hill and each time there's
always a lot of effort and it's a team
effort but i think just
um coming up with an idea for a film
i that i find relatively easy
yeah in that sense you think that goes
back to
like you were saying earlier you love to
be sort of the receiver of the story
and and not the one pushing the story
out and and
maybe you just got so good at i don't
know just absorbing stories
yeah maybe so now i absorbed all those
stories and now i can
kind of put them out right yeah maybe
yeah i i can agree with that too because
it is nice to just hear somebody
tell you about their day and believe me
there's a number of people that that's
all they want to do
and sometimes it's nice to just have
that around but i was just wondering if
if then it became just so instinctual
for you to
to push out um your own stories just
because you consume so many
and also you know capturing you know the
nuances of you know language that kind
of stuff really fascinates me and i
think you can only really do that if you
listen
very intently
and growing up in portugal is going to
the cinemaplex
part of just the normal teenage
lifestyle
for sure and also we don't in portugal
we don't really
dub films animation usually
you know is is dubbed because especially
you know for for young kids
um they obviously have to have to hear
it in portuguese but
you you always have the option for any
animated film to see it in the original
version in portugal so we don't we don't
have the kind of the dubbing practices
that for example exist in france or in
spain where it's
you know you're a bit more hard-pressed
to find the film in its original
version with engl within portuguese
subtitles yeah
do you remember the first film or one of
the first films you saw as a teenager
with friends maybe at the cinemaplex
that was an american film and how that
affected you
i think i think i saw
kids and kids definitely
is such an such an amazing
film and it's and it's a film that i
think
i mean it was it's like lightening in a
bottle and i think you can only
appreciate how much it
it really was lightning in a bottle now
when you look at like you know the first
time you know rosario dawson was on
camera
um the first time the chloe clarissa
venue was
was on camera and then just the amazing
turns from the non-actors i think it was
the first time that
that you know the kid who paid played
telly had acted
before and just watching that film and
seeing
you know what could be done if you
really embraced that
that indeed spirit you don't need a lot
of money to make a good film you really
don't
you just have to be very very smart and
very
receptive to what you know the people
that you want to work with can give you
and when you were watching those movies
was that
what inspired you to want to go to
school in london and then
ucla or what was that well i mean i i
for a long time i thought i was i would
be a video artist so i was kind of
looking more like you know purple oddie
wrist
um who's you know very very famous um
swiss
video artist looking at
other female video more like
experimental filmmakers that was kind of
the path that i thought i was going to
to take but then once i left art school
and i started working as a camera
assistant
i think that's when i was really i
really
was intrigued about maybe one day
directing something that was more
narrative
uh perhaps you know more more commercial
but still
indie because i saw that it was very
rare to work with you know a female
director or a female dp
or a female screenwriter and i i wanted
to be part of the change that
i wanted to see like sort of like cindy
sherman
cindy sherman as well of course big
reference
right and how it she was most often
right the focus of what she did so she
didn't even need a crew but
yeah and just that interesting sort of
the selfies before
selfie culture exactly and kind of
deconstructing you know
what it is to be a woman because i mean
only only a woman can answer that
question
but it was but how many times have women
been
muses right we're the thing that is is
looked at
and we don't really maybe get the
opportunity to look at ourselves
especially in like uh
in a creative artistic way and so it was
absolutely very important like cindy
sherman the gorilla girls
as well what they did was i mean it's
revolutionary it's inspiring makes you
think you know i want to be like that
when i grow up
yeah and so how did you
do it did you apply for just the one
school in london or did you apply to
others and what was the process
i applied i applied for a few i applied
to the rival
well back then it was the rival i don't
know if it still is which was
goldsmith's
so that was like all the way on the
other side of london
but in the end um i
i didn't get into goldsmiths but i got
into the slate and i also got into like
central st
martins and um and wimbledon
as well and london college of
communication but in the end i thought
the slide was was the best fit
for me and so you got your bachelor's
and then
decided you would go to ucla after that
or how did that
work so i mean i'm quite long in the
tooth so i
did my undergraduate degree worked as a
camera assistant
got some funding in portugal made my
first short film
there and i filmed that in 2012.
and then i did a few more short films in
portugal i was there for a while
i realized that if i really wanted to
have a career as an indie filmmaker that
i was
you know better off leaving because
portugal still has like a very small
film industry and then that's when i
applied for ucla and then i started the
masters there
in 2015. yeah what was your first
assignment uh for this
ucla screenwriting program um so i was
in the
the name of the program is production
slash directing
mfa and they i mean they encourage their
well really they they want their
directors to write even though there is
then a screenwriting
department which is you know very
prestigious at ucla
voice directors we we had to write and i
think
it must have been one of the first
assignments that we had we had to write
a script for just a two-minute film just
like a little tiny
it's a it's a bit of a glorified film
exercise but that was maybe one of the
first things we had to do like
year one oh wow two minute film
just a two minute yeah and it has a
three structure
a two-minute film not really but what i
think they try and teach you is that
i think you only have four hours to
shoot it and they only give you one
card so i think that
the the purpose of the exercises is to
teach you
economy which i mean is absolutely very
important
on a film set as a director being able
to make you know
fast decisions and so what was your
two-minute
um project about so that i mean that is
on
my website for free oh great okay so
it's there
um what's the domain i'm sorry what's
the name it's called
88 and at that point i had already been
in contact with
juan reynoso who who's one of my friends
and he's a teacher at compton high
school
um and he's also a professional actor
and
i had asked him you know how are any of
your kids like interested in
acting and he said yes and so he
introduced me to john wethington who was
one of his students at the time
and he is the star of ada and he
basically he goes
in for a casting audition and it's kind
of like dismissed
by the casting directors but then kind
of like you know proves his worth
to them in the space of like two minutes
yeah yeah because you know maybe this is
jumping ahead but um
i found it interesting that you said
that a lot of the people that
a lot of the students that grow up in
compton that they don't say
that they're from compton when they go
to job interviews they say south central
very interesting because they feel that
it's a bias against them
and also i mean that's something that
for example in in lisbon exists as well
the kind of you know in neighborhoods
that have
a bit of a stigma yes i know about that
right
people associate that particular
suburb in lisbon with you know crime and
poverty and all these like very
negative things and so those those kids
also when they go into job interviews
they don't they don't say they're from
burake
they say they're from imadora which is
kind of like the equivalent of not
saying you're from compton
saying you're from south central yeah
very interesting yeah even here in la i
know
applying for a job years ago and they
said to me
why do you live there and i was so
shocked you know and i've had other
people do it
it's an interesting thing and i i just
swore that i was not going to to cave
into that but i almost wonder if it
would have been easier
so that's very fascinating when i read
that it really like triggered a lot in
me that
you know you had said that because where
where i was referring to was not
considered
it was not as stigmatized as the other
areas but
um and did you focus on that in the film
did you talk about that when you finally
did your feature did you explore this
so the feature kind of talks a bit more
about
um the the stigma
of having of you know being daca
eligible or tps eligible and having that
status
potentially revoked and then becoming
undocumented
which you know is is a
a status in and of itself so it kind of
talks more about that than about
you know just generally competent per se
right okay and when were you planning
when did you
already started writing this film was
this before 2016
or no i started writing the script for
la la in the negra i think at the end of
2017.
so like maybe october november i think i
had like the first act
yeah right i know i'm jumping ahead here
sorry but i was just i was just curious
about the timing
so that was how you sort of got your
foot in the door with compton high
school was
in doing the two-minute to go back to
that and i'm sorry i'm i'm jumping
around but yeah
okay so interesting so you kind of
already
knew the world a little bit maybe they
trusted you and
you were able to go in and meet some of
the students yeah
so that's kind of where it started but
then i did another short film
again in compton with mr rayno so where
he played a cop
uh and and so i'd done a few films
with compton non-actors and then that
eventually led to
the feature what advice would you give
to
other artists coming from other
countries who want to
come to los angeles to attend college
make movies here
i would say that probably the thing
that enabled me to come to la was the
fact that i had a very generous
scholarship from the callisto benkian
foundation
which is a portuguese institution that
is very committed to helping
young artists um to do
to basically for for master programs
um also for any kind of like workshops
or like
training initiatives like they're really
good at
at helping their young artists and i
think especially for international
students coming to la
i mean if you can get any kind of help
that's really instrumental because
obviously i'm sure you can imagine that
the fees for an international student
are eye-ordering to say the least
right right and then once a student from
another country comes here
any advice on what they can do um how
they can acclimate better to the la
i know it's it's culture shock for
everybody even coming from northern
california
i mean i think that you know the the
ucla network
i mean that's the one that i know the
most intimately it's
it's huge and it's very welcoming and
you know that's that's something that is
encouraged
at the ucla film school like we all crew
on each other's films
all of us you know because i i camera
assisted so i aced on like a bunch
of shorts and features when i was at
ucla and then people you know returned
the favor
and i i'd like to say that it's the same
at usc and afi but i'm not entirely sure
but i think that once you get once you
tap into one of those
networks like things take care of
themselves because people
want to help each other to to make films
together
you know we had a video that we posted
where someone just talked about short
films and
in the beginning they had people work on
them for free and vice versa and
there was sort of you know it's an
understanding in the indie film
community and
especially in the beginning of someone's
career that you're going to help out and
i know some people had some backlash to
that because
they said well you're encouraging
artists to work for free and not be paid
i understand that that isn't a problem
but
especially when you're coming up quote
unquote it seems like that's part of
paying your dues in a way
and the thing i i mean because iac'd
for free after having worked as a
professional
on so many films i feel that it's like
i think you can only ask for a favor
if you've done a favor for that person
or you're going to do a favor so i
always make a point of like you know if
someone crewed for me i would
absolutely 100 crew for them like you
don't even have to ask me you know just
tell me what time
to be there and i will be there with all
my kit and i won't charge you a cent
because and you were there for me when i
needed help so
i'm gonna be there for you and i think
you know your word is your bond i think
it's all that you have
in this industry so i'm very um
conscientious of of doing that always
what would you say is your filmmaking
style i think the kind of films that i
love
to watch and therefore are the films
that kind of i
seek to make are kind of you know very
very indie very raw
very rugged kind of you know rough
around the edges
but films that have their heart in the
right place
i think definitely that's the kind of
filmmaking that i gravitate
towards and filmmakers who take risks
like big risks are the ones that you
know i
i look up to and want to emulate so even
growing up you you weren't maybe drawn
as much toward the blockbusters
as as some of these i would do the same
thing i would look for these raw
gritty like indie films that you
sometimes even saw the boom mic hanging
down
just because the story there was
something
because that's the thing it's like i
think that the
you know again i guess just to go back
to kids because
i mentioned it before it's like there
are i
distinctly remember like a section in
kids where it's
the two the two male protagonists
they're talking on a subway train and
one of them like
blocks the other and technically
speaking that would be wrong
like oh no no we next this camera angle
but the camera just like
sits there and it waits for him to just
lean back
and it's things like that that it's it's
you feel that it's not really about
what's right in a film or what's
technically correct it's about the story
and that's always
the thing that is going to make you keep
coming back to a film is the story
because it's so good it's so engaging
and i mean come on let's face it i mean
there are quite a few blockbusters that
you watch and you think
how on earth did this script get
greenlit
like how how much love went into this
script
i'm not i'm i'm wondering how much love
went into it whereas like you watch a
film like
like fish tank again because andre
arnold is one of my
of my absolute favorites or moonlight
how how much passion went into that
script you know that it did it's
you you can't question it it's it's
there to to see
to feel um and and that's
sometimes my issue with big blockbuster
films is i wonder just how much heart
is really in them and also it feels like
with a lot of indie films there the the
writer directors are okay with having
a question at the end where it's not in
a pretty box
and i think there's something nice about
that because that's what life is i mean
yeah we don't know i mean to say
something very dark and very greek
the only pretty box you can expect at
the end of life is the coffin right
let's face it very true yeah right
right okay that makes sense but but yeah
i mean and
i think that is the problem that either
people have against indie films or
or for them is that the ending isn't
always
you know um there's a question at the
end and i like that
you know i'd rather have a question
rather than know exactly
how does instinct factor into filmmaking
i think especially for a director it's
really
uh crucial really critical because i
think
you know sometimes on on set you have to
be able to look at a performance
and know is this is this going to work
is it not gonna work because i think i
think
sometimes you're not really sure if
anything's gonna work 100
so all you've got is your gut and i
think especially
you know i like when i'm asked oh you
know what would you tell like young
filmmakers i always say that you've got
to trust your instincts
because even if you get it wrong it
doesn't matter you'll make a better film
next time around
and you learn so much more from failure
than you do from success so just don't
be afraid and don't make any excuses
and did that instinct go into casting
for your first feature
for sure and i think especially i mean i
i
want to say especially with non-actors
you have to be able to see something in
them that maybe they don't necessarily
see
themselves right and how was that for
you to try
not not maybe convince but but
encourage and some of these actors that
maybe they weren't i don't know were
they
did they take dramatic arts or or you
saw something in them and just knew it
and then showing that in them i mean i
think that most of them were
were really beginners first timers
i'm not too sure if they had done any
like
little sketches in class or anything
like that
i can't speak to that but i think that
in terms of like
being on camera they didn't really have
any experience at all
but you know i mean i was reading i was
reading an interview the other day
that sofia lauren gave
and she was saying that you know even in
all her years as a professional actress
and as a start
the thing that she wants most of all
from a director
is trust and kind of you know
i think she was saying this about
vittorio de sika that
he had more faith than me than i had in
myself
and that was so important to me as an
actress
so i think that's what you know when you
make your casting choices if you really
believe in an
in an actor or an actress that's what
you got to make them feel is that
i trust you a hundred percent i've got
you
you can do this so let's go yeah
patricia can you give us a snapshot of
what your day is like in terms of
even in your free time if you're putting
in work on your filmmaking career
or thinking about ideas what's what's
your day like
i've definitely been doing a lot of
writing
and especially kind of working on
fiction film treatment i'll be doing a
lot of that also developing a tv pilot
um with one of my producers from la
linda negra
um with marcel perez and using
that to to go into meetings and also to
apply for like um
init like tv initiatives for example
um that are kind of looking for you know
pilot scripts
so i do i do a lot of that i spend a lot
of time in front of a computer
um and then and then for fun
i love i love to dance i do a lot of
like latin dances
you know i like salsa there's this
brazilian dance called fojo as well
which i enjoy very much
so definitely if i've got some free time
i'm usually
trying to get a dance in now is that
with um at a like a class
or with just friends um
can be kind of both every now and then
if i have time to like you know go to a
class i'll go and do a class
but then they're also just socials you
know like one of them
one of the clubs that's very close to
where i live is um
the warehouse in marina del rey and they
have salsa dancing every friday night so
that's really fun
and then fojo in la they'll organize uh
socials like maybe once a month in an
art gallery
called tropico de nopal which is in
downtown
and they those parties are great because
they'll usually they'll have a live band
so i love dancing i love music so
anytime i can do that i'm
definitely there do you think filmmaking
is like dancing in some ways i know it's
been compared to
jazz or math or different you know
there's just like filmmaking is not this
or that
but in terms of getting everyone on
board and doing the right steps
absolutely i do think that there's
definitely an element of um
choreography but i have to quote
um robert rodriguez because he had such
a good uh
um analogy for what film filmmaking is
and he said
it's it's cooking basically that when
you write i think he said when you write
the script that's that's you making a
shopping list
right you're you're writing down all the
things you're going to need
to to cook and then when you're on set
with your actors
that's you actually making the dish and
then when you're
in the post-production phase when you're
in the edit suite
that's you actually getting to sample
what you eat because that's when it's
you can actually really see what you've
made is in the in the edit suite
so i thought that was that's actually
the best metaphor i've heard
that's great yeah i did not hear that
one before i like that yeah that's great
i know we went dark a few minutes ago
and i'm going to go dark with something
if today was your last day as a
filmmaker
how would you begin your next day doing
something different
what would your life be like so in the
sense if i like had to
do something that wasn't making films
right you were forbidden there were
there was a rule there was a loss
something happened
and they said sorry you can't be a
filmmaker anymore
um i think i would i think i would still
write
because i do enjoy writing
even with all its ups and downs and
lonely boats because i think writing can
be quite lonely
um i still enjoy it and i enjoy
researching
a lot so if i was still allowed to do
that i think that's what
i would do so when you say research
do you do you not view it as you know
some people say well research can become
procrastination
do you view it as a way to get to know
your character absolutely
and just like i mean just yesterday i
was working on on the tv pilot that i'm
developing with my producer and it's set
in
miami so i mean there probably there is
an element of procrastination
but like you know watching videos where
you know miami locals explain the
intricacies of miami slang
that's that's important if you want to
have some of that like authentic miami
flavor
in your script you've got to you've got
to hear what
well how people talk you know the words
that they use what
in what context they use them you know
what what do the what the cubanos
use in miami like that's that's
important to
to hear and understand was there a new
word that you didn't know was a term for
something
um there was um
there was oh there was one which was
hilarious
which apparently cuban someone was
saying that oh my cuban grandmother used
to say this all the time
because she didn't approve of my of my
boyfriend
which i think it was um
which is that egg only wants salt which
means he only wants one thing
isn't that hilarious i love but that's
so good
it is yeah let's go grandma okay
that's really great say it one more time
it's beautiful yeah i love it
um you could do voiceovers too by the
way
yeah it's a beautiful voice okay sorry
just a side note
what makes a great story i think what
makes a great story for me
is feeling that the writer has
put some of themselves
in it and you know that that thing can
be
it can be love it can be passion it can
be hard
but definitely i think i need to feel
like in some
way like even if it's a sci-fi story or
you know some some more or a fantasy
genre but to feel that they have kind of
they've opened the vein
to tell you this story
did you see the last black man in san
francisco i did
i i mean i don't know why it didn't get
more buzz it should have maybe just
in the bay area it did but um i saw it
twice in theater and
i really felt that they they i mean it's
a personal story
to to one of the gentlemen but they
really put
that that's an example of that sorry is
it jimmy do you remember the name
oh gosh it's the jimmy fails i think
that's
it yeah he was the one that was the
skateboarder he was yeah protagonist
yeah
and he's excellent he was yeah
absolutely he's just such a
such a good actor um
and and also so beautifully shot the
film and yeah and i think that he did he
wrote
he wrote that script i think even maybe
it possibly collaborated with the
director as well
i think so right and it was like sort of
loosely based i think on his life
and he lived in group homes i think if i
remember correctly
but and i loved the character the two
the two leads in it
just playing off of each other because
one of them had more of like a safer
home life
i think danny glover was his father or
grandfather and and then just
you know being able to stay over there
but knowing that this isn't really my
home
and he would stay there and just seeing
how he kind of wanted to be this free
bird
and and i don't know it was just a
beautiful film and i wish it i wish you
got more attention
how do you know if an idea is worth
developing into a story
i have a sounding board who is
i guess he's kind of my secret weapon
but he's he's someone who's
you know he's seen he's seen all my
short films and he's always the first
person i go to
with with an idea like even a treatment
uh stage to be like
is this any good or is this like really
terrible and if it is really terrible
can i salvage it
you know is there a way to make it
better and it's um it's a very good
friend
called faisal a qureshi and he's a
professional screenwriter
and he's based in the uk he's also
directed uh
films and he i think it's very important
as a writer to be able to show
someone that you trust something that
you're not entirely sure if it's any
good or not
because he no he knows me well enough
now that he knows that he can be really
harsh and it's okay because at the end
of the day i just want to know if i'm
wasting my time or not um and he has
been very harsh and i really appreciate
it
um because i have had instances where
it's like i've sent him a treatment
and he'll tell me what's wrong with it
like in a very kind of brutal way but
then that's good because it helps me
figure out how i can make it
better and i have actually been able to
like make it better and like get onto
fellowships with treatments that before
he was like
i don't think so yeah and do you
does he reciprocate in terms of he sends
you his
scripts he does yeah he has sent me his
materials
before so definitely i think that that's
so important
is to have someone because i think
definitely i always feel like in this
industry you only really get like one
chance to like impress people so you
want to send them
you want to put your best foot forward
and that's why it's important to have
someone
who whose opinion you trust and whose
craft you
you really admire and you recognize that
they're really talented and they're
really intelligent
and you can just show them like your
worst stuff
and they will you know give you
suggestions um and will tell you
maybe what you could do to make it a
little bit better
does he ever ask you to be more harsh
does he
oh yeah yeah like just just tell me like
i don't
like did he have to encourage or because
i could see you
not wanting to hurt someone's feelings
absolutely very much so
and and yet he's like you know like
you're like just be honest like please
just like tell me because i do i do
always think like i don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings
yeah right yeah i think that'd be really
important to have a a
you know working relationship or just a
friendship with someone where you could
give them
and you know that they're not trying to
wound you to stop you but they're just
trying to
help make you better and i think that's
a rare thing to find absolutely
so that's why you know big shout out to
to faisal nice and i think someone who
kind of
you know because they they've read your
previous work and they've seen like your
previous films that they kind of
they they know what you're trying to do
and
and because of that they can tell you i
know i think i know what you're trying
to do but you're maybe you're not doing
it
the best way that you could do it so let
me just you know ask you some questions
and and you know make some suggestions
because i think i know where you're
trying to get i think that's very
important because i mean there are some
people who you just don't understand
your work and don't understand your
films and you know don't want to and
maybe not the best people
to get feedback from how do you know
personally when your movie idea isn't
working
not not so much if you've given it to
someone as a sounding board but
personally
i think that it's when you
you yourself are writing it and you are
not excited
by what you're writing i think that i
think you know
that it's working when you're like you
know i
really want to keep you know i want to
keep going i want to know i personally
want to know what happens next
but if you're kind of like trudging
through it and you're like oh
god i have to write another five pages
or i have to write you know another
another you know five five like you know
five paragraphs of this treatment if you
yourself are having that thought
trust me whoever is reading it is gonna
also have
the same thought of oh god i have to
read another five pages before this is
over
yeah have you ever abandoned an idea
like you've been excited about it for a
little while and then realized your
heart wasn't in it
i think yeah definitely but i think more
with like um i mean i have had that with
a feature script yeah which i was like
this is not working as a feature but i
managed to kind of recycle it
into something else um
and then also short films like you know
if you if you've you know written a
short film script that was a
collaboration with
with a friend and then you apply to a
lot of funding and you just keep getting
rejected and then it's like okay well
then let's just not
so the universe was telling you
something or at least you took it that
way
and then you just move on to the next
project because that got funding okay
well then i'll just do that
yeah what did your experience
going to two colleges one that was an
art school one that taught
directing writing producing what process
did they teach you for building story
and
is that a process that you use now i
think
definitely at art school i mean i
i was making loosely narrative pieces
so not not really traditionally
narrative films and i think that
definitely in art school
in in terms of you know story in terms
of communication
i think that what they they teach us to
experiment
you know that if there are any rules you
know they're there to be
broken and so it gives you
kind of a fearlessness and a willingness
to you know
to to bend rules and to you know do what
you feel is right but then
on the flip side it's also good to to be
very aware of what those rules
are and i think that that's what going
to ucla
gave me because we did have you know
screenwriting classes with you know a
lot of really
excellent professors i had you know
richard walter i had linda voorhees
i had george gary as well so i think
definitely yeah ucla was very
instrumental for
for helping me learn the classical rules
of screenwriting so then once you learn
the rules then it's okay to play with
them
and break them or kind of you know
turn them around or different things
interesting
so that that idea of the the rebel
writer that doesn't totally know the
rules and wants to break all of them
maybe that's more fantasy because
if you don't really know the rules and
what you're breaking
is it good you know is it going to be
something worth broken i don't know
i guess it depends it depends on what
kind of film you want to make because
like
i mean i'm not too sure how the process
of that
of that script came about but like if
you look at daughters of the dust i mean
that's not a traditional
film structure but it's very effective
because
i don't think that julie dash was really
trying to make like you know
like a classic you know three-act
structure
film i mean i think if you want to
explore like different ways
of of storytelling then
then maybe yeah you don't really need to
study the rules as much if that's your
end
goal will you ever write a screenplay
without outlining first
no i personally wouldn't
because i actually think it's very um
helpful
because sometimes the the the outline is
kind of
the the road signs the markers
you know because i think that once
especially if you know if you start
writing a screenplay and you're you're
in the flow
um sometimes it's good to be like oh
yeah that's where i am
okay and then you know where to go next
i i personally find it just practically
very useful
everyone talks about writing authentic
characters
we all want that and we all want to
watch that but how do you know you're
writing an authentic character and how
easy is it i think
that especially if if
you are i mean if you're writing about
anyone who isn't you i think it's very
important to do
research and what i mean by research is
kind of like you know i mean i i kind of
employed a near realist
strategy in in la in la negra where i i
cast
um teenagers from the community that i
was
portraying and i think that that's what
you know that's what you need if you
want to try
and make a character more authentic
because you really have to like
you know sit down and interact and spend
time and like
listen to to the kids in order
to like you know capture their their
unique voices
when you had done the two-minute film
which was your first project at ucla
did you already have the idea for your
feature film
no not yet you hadn't okay no
so then you went back a second time and
you did the short film where it was
it wasn't a spelling bee but it was an
audition uh so that was the
the first so the first short okay
was the audition um was 88 and then this
the second short film that i shot in
compton with and also had mr
juan reynoso in it and that was called
the hood and that was shot in 2016.
but lolli and then it was only shot in
2018.
ah okay at what point though did you say
you know what i feel
i want to tell more stories from this
community how do i
how do i get this feature going and how
do i come back and pose this question
so you had to use the schools right as
well right yeah we did yeah we were
lucky enough to
to get to shoot at compton high school
but even that wasn't that easy that i
mean my producers can attest to the fact
that that was quite
a process getting permission to to shoot
there
but i think you know i couldn't have
done it without the
the help and support of of mr rayno so
um
so he was definitely you know
instrumental that when i communicated to
him like you know i mean i
i enjoyed you know shooting in compton
so much and you know i really
really loved the the people and the
stories and the urban environment
i mean he was the one who kind of said
yep sure anytime you want to
you want to come to class i'll introduce
you to my kids who
who are interested in in acting and you
can just take it from there
so then did you go back and write a
script
and have certain people that you'd
already met in mind
i did already have some some people
already in mind
but i think that when i started the
casting process
i think i had a first draft and i
started the casting process
in january of 2018.
and did you ever envision that this film
would go to sundance oh definitely not
no not at all so it wasn't like you said
hey guys we're going to shoot this film
and our goal is to go there
and you and you sort of prep them
i mean you can always you can always say
like
um oh you know this film is gonna go
here
here and there but you don't know i
don't think anybody really knows
well unless you're like super mega
successful and you already know
exactly what you what you're doing with
your life but none of us did
wow how do you write a great scene
i personally think that
you you write a first version
which is what you as a writer think you
know this is what the scene
needs to do this is the function that
the scene has
in in the film i mean just just as a
basic scene goal you know advancing the
plot of the thing
of the of the film or like you know
establishing an important dynamic or an
important
connection and then i personally what i
like to do is then workshop it with the
actors
and have you know give them the
opportunity to kind of like okay you
know the first time we run it
let's let's stick to the to the script
and then the second time we run it feel
free to improvise
you know feel free to you know live live
your character and live
your character in this specific moment
in this specific space with your
with your scene partner and then and
then from that you can get these really
you know precious moments these like
gems that then what i
then do is write them back into the
shooting script
how does a screenwriter decide a story
ending
well i can say that for la le and la
negra i had to campaign
for the open ending because i was
often told um that american audiences do
not like
open endings and can't do that
that's like a european thing that's not
okay
interesting yeah but i thought long and
hard about
why i thought an open ending was right
and i reached the conclusion that the
reason that
we need the film needs to end that way
is because there's so much
instability and so much insecurity
in these kids lives because you know tps
is not a path to citizenship and neither
is dhaka
so these kids do not know what's going
to happen
no one knows what's going to happen and
so it make
made more sense for me to conclude the
film
on that note of instability
and precariousness and uncertainty as
kind of symbolic of the predicament
of these tps eligible kids
and you've done another story i think it
was a short film of three
young women that were all from different
backgrounds
want one more impoverished and i think
the one in the middle maybe not so much
and then the other one a little more
from a privilege more like quote safer
environment
is that something that you've always
been interested in just sort of
environment and how we grow up and how
it shapes us
and definitely like urban environments
because i mean i'm very much like
you know i i grew up as a city kid and i
think that that's definitely especially
because you
you mentioned lisbon i mean that's one
of the things that i just love about
lisbon
is that i mean i think any you know big
cosmopolitan
city has this but you know the melting
pot of different
cultures because you know in in lisbon
we've got you know
there are there are brazilians there are
people from angola there are people from
mozambique there are people from
cape verde you know there there are
people from macau
in china there are you know um
people from east timor as well and it's
it's they're all
all like coming together is it's so it's
so unique and it's so
special and it's something that you know
when i was a teenager it excited me and
it still excites me to
this day is that cultural melting pot
so when you went to compton high school
for the first time what did you notice
about the students and their reception
of a filmmaker coming there to feature
them
or their stories i think that definitely
the kids who were
you know interested in acting were the
ones who were the most
excited especially because you know
i mean the the majority of the cast of
the film is is latino
and at least from what they told me like
it's you know
if i have a conversation with my parents
where i say like oh i want to act
they'll be like oh that's nice how are
you going to help us pay the bills
so it's for them it's like this might be
their only opportunity
to to be in a film
ever and so for them it's like they
they kind of really seized the
opportunity
and i kind of really you know i mean i
needed
them i needed their their creative
talents
to to make the the film
really and and so i think that they were
very
very open and very excited
and it's i mean i'm i'm very thankful
and very grateful
for all the the time and the energy and
the dedication that they put in and i
feel in a lot of ways that the film is
as much
theirs as it is mine did anybody
at first maybe put up walls and say she
doesn't know us i mean no offense here
i'm just going to play the devil's
advocate
she's she's hollywood she doesn't know
us why is she here and then
they changed well i don't think anybody
thinks i'm hollywood
okay you know i think
it would be different if i was i don't
think anybody okay
i think they always definitely saw that
i was like you know scruffy impoverished
um
student filmmaker um so i don't think
that they
okay i don't think so
how much time did you spend writing la
linda negra so i
started writing that i want to say
november of 2017
and the shooting script was more or less
solidified
by june june 2018
and what was it that made you want to
tell the story
i think it was after i met the the kids
at compton
high and a lot of them are were latino
and they go through what every other
american teenager goes through but also
a lot of them have immigration statuses
that are currently being
revoked by this administration um so
i i wanted to talk about that and kind
of you know the the fear and the
insecurity and anxiety
that they felt what made writing this
film either easier or
more difficult than anything you'd ever
done before i think it was
easier in the sense that it was just
such um it was such a pleasure
to you know work with the kids and hang
out with the kids and kind of you know
play and collaborate with them i mean
that
that was just fun it was just i mean it
was work as well but it was um
it was wonderful it was real pleasure
um and i think i think the
hardest thing about
about writing the script
or was it more about making the film
could be both
okay or maybe just that you had to say
goodbye to the kids at some point
i'm sure that was i mean yeah i mean
that is it is true that
you spend such a long time with a film
that you know that you're writing it and
then you're casting and then you're
rehearsing a location scouting and then
you're actually shooting it that i think
that when
the film ends you feel almost like
you you know you're bereft you know
you feel like you've you've lost a loved
a loved thing you know if not a loved
one but a loved thing when
the film is concluded
and since you didn't expect to go to
sundance and then
how did you announce the news to the
these actors from compton high that
the film was going there um i mean i was
very practical about it i emailed
everybody
saying good news yeah um
and then i think and then of course then
we all met you know and then the
sundance and it was you know to see
their like you know
big wide-eyed um joy was very special
how did you pitch the film to investors
well i was very
lucky to have the support of the kalu
school banking foundation so that helped
a lot that was like to be honest the
majority of the film's
budget um and then and then i did also
have an executive producer julianna
politski who um she had she already knew
of my work like she'd seen my short
films before and
she really liked them and i think she
like she really believed in me um and so
once we had like
a first assembly me and my editor i sent
her like
a link to the film and she and that's
when she came on board as an executive
producer so she also helped a lot
and then obviously you know ucla helped
as well you know in terms of like
providing equipment
and that kind of like logistical support
but i wouldn't say that i really i
didn't really pitch to juliana i just
kind of showed her the film
as opposed to pitching yeah oh so did
you have like a sizzle reel or anything
like that when you showed it to her
um i still heard like the whole the
whole film i just sent her a link to
like a first
edit oh so she came on after you had
already shot oh i'm sorry okay i didn't
understand that oh
okay is the film available for people to
watch
now um it's on the festival circuit now
so you know hopefully we'll be coming to
a town near you
in terms of festival screenings but we
do have a sales agent and who's
currently in talks with you know
potential distributors
did you receive any pushback being a
first-time director
that possibly you shouldn't direct the
film that you should have someone else
that had
done multiple feature films well
i mean because i was in the directing
program i mean in order to graduate i
had to make
a thesis film um and i think that
definitely there were people who were
like are you sure you want to make a
feature maybe you could just make like a
short like you know kind of like a proof
of concept and then you know you could
use that to then you know
um pitch to investors and then you could
make your feature further down the line
for me it was like this might be the
only chance
i ever get to make a feature in america
i mean i can make you know features in
portugal you know further down the line
or in europe and i won't have any issues
but this is
the only opportunity i've got that i
know that
that i can make a feature right here
right now
what was the most emotional day you had
on set i think the most emotional
day was when we were shooting a very
emotional scene which is um
elitea gets gets the bad news that her
scholarship has been
revoked and she has kind of you know a
confrontation with her
with her stepfather um and
the actress like she did such a good job
like you know monica
betancoud like she she really just
brought the house down
and she and and you know the the the
take in which she cried like i
cried as well and then we both cried
together and
my first day dee had to like give us
both a moment
and you had people being like what's the
holdup and it's like they're crying
just give them a second they're crying
together yeah
but it was it was good because i knew
she'd really
she brought it you know and
if forgive me if this is this is too
personal we can turn it
off and switch topics but i believe that
you both lost your father's at a fairly
young age
well she had lost her father very
recently i think her father had passed
away
in january of 2018
i think so so very recently i mean i i
lost my father when i was 22 years old
so that was
you know a bit a bit longer ago but
definitely i think that she was very
much
channeling that that loss
and and then in your home you have sort
of a shrine or some
a memory it was it's monika actually
she had and she showed me that they had
like a sort of
of of shrine for her father in her
in her home in um in compton
and with like all these like photographs
and then like a little
like a little bottle of like favorite
tequila as well
yeah so so the two of you had that
sort of as a bond and and
you saw her and even though she said she
was very seemed very shy you saw
strengthen her for sure yeah and she is
she's very very strong despite her youth
like she's a very strong woman and in
the film
these these high school people are these
high school students are their member of
some type of a
political club um in
the in the movie itself i
you know created a fictitious
underground political organization
called the compton black bloc
which kind of has anarchist affiliations
uh but as far as i know i don't i
don't know any of the students
themselves have
you know no no but in the film in the
film though yes so that's fictitious i
mean i get i get asked about that a lot
like oh is that really a thing and it's
like no
i don't think so oh other people are
curious yeah yeah
do you notice that that this generation
is
is much more politically active than
than maybe millennials or or just
gen z in general just because they're
presented with many more things
that i mean myself as a gen xer wasn't
presented with
do you see that at all um i mean i think
at least from what i've seen that it
seems to be like two ends of
of the spectrum either they're like you
know pretty apathetic and don't really
you know they're not very interested
in politics or they have very very
strong
so what i see is that um polarization
between those two uh views
interesting what do you think makes one
more so than the other just because
one's been affected um and i think if
you're
if you're directly affected by you know
the police policy some of the policies
of the of the administration i think
you're
you know you're probably much more
likely to have some
some response to that whereas if it
doesn't affect you or anyone that
that you know it's a bit like meh is
at least what i have seen for your next
film
uh you said you want to do a narrative
or i know you're working on tv
projects as well but would it be in a
similar vein just about people
and home and what they consider home and
losing certain things
i mean definitely you know the why a
stories interest me
very much you know the coming of age
stories
uh the latino space interests me a lot
as well um and also like women you know
female driven narratives i think
like those are kind of like in my
previous work that's that's what i've
always gravitated towards
so i would yeah very much like to
continue you know exploring that
that space when you submitted the film
to sundance did you submit a rough cut
no we had we had picture locked
and i think we had like a temp mix
uh okay yeah okay and did you
ex i mean expect to did you do it
thinking that you really had a good
chance or you thought you know what let
me just try this
it was it was more the latter oh really
okay more like now let's
let's just try because i think that's
all you can do you know
i think that we you know we have a a
saying in portugal which is the no is
guaranteed so why not try for the yes
how do you say it i'd love to hear it
like
okay i mean at least that's you know how
i've heard it so it's like you know why
not try
why not you know give it a whirl what
were some of the best things that
happened to you at sundance
uh i think it was definitely for me
the the audience response i think that
was definitely
what you know what it was that kind of
um
you know validation really of like you
know having someone
i remember a lady who came up at uh the
end
of the premiere at the egyptian theater
and she said you know i didn't even know
what your film was about i didn't even
read the synopsis i just knew i had like
a couple of free hours this afternoon so
i just came here and i watched your film
and i loved it i mean i was
i i didn't know that this was happening
to these young kids and my heart really
broke for them
and i would love to know what i can do
as an american
to to help these you know tps eligible
kids
uh you know like because the film really
liked it you know it
it woke me up and for me it's like well
that's ex that's exactly why i made the
film
for me that was definitely like the best
thing
did you have a q a afterwards always
after every single screening there was
always a q a yes
what's the most common question they ask
um the
oh the significance of the title or you
know what motivated you to shoot in
black and white
those tend to be pretty pretty commonly
asked
and can you tell me more about the title
and what comes into play with that
so um la la in la negra it essentially
refers
to a historical bias
and it's uh the term that protest
settlers used to to
refer to the spanish conquistadors
um and basically you know the character
velite she challenges all bias
in her fight for truth um and this is
reflected in the scene that she kind of
stands up for herself
in history class but also it's reflected
in her involvement
in the underground political
organization the compton black bloc
and because the film kind of considers
you know cycles of history
and imperialism both old and new la
lenda negra refers
to um the that historical bias but it's
also
a nod to ella there's involvement in
anarchist
circles because if you translate la la
la negra
it means the black legend
and what is the scene in the history
class just briefly what is that
so that's um where the the teacher has
just
shown this this uh carlos fuentes
documentary
uh where he kind of talks about you know
the conquistadores and like you know the
like you know cortez's uh
uh arrival in in mexico
uh and the teacher kind of makes some
some affirmations that then elite
challenges
in front of the entire class ah okay
it was that a breaking moment where she
kind of came out of her shell
exactly yes interesting
did you get a phone call from sundance
yes oh okay what did they say like
ring ring hey this is it it was one of
the programmers
oh nice um but to be honest when um
i mean i i i didn't really i think i
thought it was a prank when i first
got i was like susan this is someone
making a very mean joke
at my expense that's what i thought it
was
um and then it was like hmm maybe i
didn't like you know i was worried that
i might have hallucinated the phone call
but then when i started to get emails
from artist relations i was like oh no
this might actually
have happened yeah oh wow so when you
got the phone call you just thought it
was someone like
were you playing along with it and
you're like okay at some moment you're
gonna figure out who it is
uh well yes i was just kind of like
listening yeah i was just like listening
listening and but then i was like
oh wow no i actually think that i am
really talking to a programmer
yeah okay
it's not a telemarketer yeah yeah i'm
not selling you uh
solar panels okay what do you think the
secret is to having your film accepted
at sundance
because they say oh you have to know
somebody these different things
what do you think the secret is i think
i mean because i did meet the the
programmer
at sundance who said to me like you know
i when i saw your film i was the one who
kind of you know
flagged it to all my colleagues and was
like this film has
you know has got to be programmed um
and he said you know i mean i just you
know i
i was moved by your film so i think that
at least what he told me was that the
film
touched him so i don't know
i is i don't know if that means that
that's that's the secret
or going back to what we talked to in
previous questions just
that authentic voice and and putting
part of yourself
did you feel a part of yourself in the
story definitely definitely
like you know the the i think i've been
you know the character of elite
and rosarito and even the character of
monica at like different points in my
life so definitely there was
you know versions of me in in them
yeah right so did you did you think back
to growing up in portugal or
is this more when you've gone to college
you've sort of been out of your
quote-unquote home country sure
yeah definitely you know the immigrant
experience
and then just you know growing up i
think as
a young girl into a young woman
in the film were the parents also
undocumented or
because did they have that were was part
of the story that they had the child
here in the states
and they and they themselves were
undocumented no
um a letter the character of aletaya was
born
in el salvador and then um came with her
mother
as an infant to america but in the story
um elite's mother has already passed
away
and elite lives with her stepfather so
there's no
you know the there's not really any
blood relation
between alite and the character of juan
in the film
so she's really sort of without a family
in some sense except for maybe her
classmates and her stepdad yeah
okay interesting how do you feel about
what you've accomplished so far
and what do you want to accomplish next
well i feel very
very lucky very grateful um
and definitely i would like to continue
making
features that's definitely kind of the
the end goal
is to keep keep writing keep pitching
keep developing and
have you know more features down the
pipeline
do you remember something that was said
to you in one of these ucla writing
classes that you never forgot
yeah definitely um richard walter
um said you know nobody
wants to see you know the film of the
village of the nice happy people i just
remember that one
because it's so true yeah
and also he said something which is in
in hollywood all you do is
graduate to the next level of
disappointment
you know like i think usually the
example that you write the script but it
doesn't sell
you know it's it's uh short but it's not
distributed
it's distributed but not for not in
great venues
so you you basically just graduate to
the next level
which is very grounding you know it's
very grounding advice that
you know it's you're always going to be
working the tight rope in this industry
you know no matter how well you think
you're doing you're always working the
tightrope
very interesting so also coming with
more of
you know we're saying like the european
mindset of just try it and see what
happens which
i like that i like that mindset do you
think that
coupled with that piece of advice has
helped you to be like you know what
i'm going to try it and yeah why not i
will submit to sundance and some people
their first film i mean that what a
major accomplishment
but to always like you know keep your
your feet on the ground
you know because because i mean that's
something that
he he would say to us you know as as a
screenwriter like
the the secret to success is
self-motivated
you know speculative writing you know if
you just like sit around and you wait
for people to come to you
that's not gonna happen you just need to
have your own engine
and you have to keep moving forward
regardless
and is that what then sort of at what
point when you heard that
did you then go and approach mr reynoso
was it
at compton high and and ask him to then
work with you with your feature did you
hear that before
or or before you do it okay yeah you're
very interesting
i think that richard walters class was
one of the first ones that i took
at ucla for screenwriting great
do you think that that other people not
just that statement in general but
would react to something like that you
know we
maybe i'm more of this old mindset where
people kind of expected to be picked for
things and i don't think that's the case
anymore
or maybe it's less so do you think do
you think there was a reaction
to people thinking that i have to be the
one to like drum up
excitement or or not i mean
some people want to be picked and
there's also
a feeling of i've arrived if i'm picked
if i have to push this out then
it must not you know you know what i'm
saying but i think that's an old mindset
do you think that
the newer generations are of the mindset
of i need to keep working at this and
i'm the one that makes this happen
yeah i mean i think definitely like what
i hear
every every young creative in la
say all the time is that the hustle is
real
there you go okay right you can never
get comfortable
you know just because you know things
are good now
doesn't mean that it's that they're
gonna stay that way so you've really got
to just
keep keep working um keep collaborating
keep making um and just you know
stay stay focused because you know i've
had you know very successful
filmmakers say to me that you know the
reason
that i'm still making films and the
colleagues
that i you know worked with or grew up
with are no longer making films is not
because
i'm more talented than them it's just i
kept going when they gave up
that's the difference it's just
persistence and
focus and drive and determination like
that's that's what is going to
keep you moving forward what film do you
watch where you say
i wish i could have made that i think
fish tank
yeah because it's a film that
you know you watch and you know the
cinematography is brilliant the
performances are brilliant
the story is engaging the dialogue is is
just
right like it's really it's a flawless
film
from start to finish where were you the
first time you saw it
i think in london i think i might have
been
studying in london when that film came
out
and definitely it's it's the film
that that makes that made me want to
make films
[Music]
sorry it was a porsche repair shop very
noisy
i think they they test them
what is the hardest part of writing for
you i think
at least at least for me um
you need to have a lot of discipline
to write and i i remember
because i visited um his house in key
west that like
ernest hemingway like he would have
uh a practice of like no matter what he
would always like you know block out
like four or five hours in the morning
to write no matter what he would do that
every single day
you know some days he would write a lot
some days he would just write like two
words but he would always block out
those hours
to write and so i think that that's
maybe the hardest thing is you know
really maintaining that discipline
and that self motivation because writing
can be
kind of lonely how many hours a day do
you write do you do the same thing
i have to say that i'm not as
disciplined as earnest i think where it
was
um because i need what i really need to
do is i need to like turn off my phone
because i get very easily distracted
like if i get a message or if i get a
phone call
and what i need to do is i need to be
completely focused and then i can just
kind of plow through
pages that way
do you set goals for yourself definitely
i'll be like okay
you know i know i need to get like 30
pages by the end of this week
so you know i work out okay so i'll do
do five this day six this day maybe this
day i'll do four so then the next day i
can do so so i
i definitely try and like uh figure out
what my
my daily goals are to work to the big
goal when you write your first draft of
something
what's your next step do you put it away
do you
send it to somebody that you know will
give you honest maybe brutal feedback
what is your plan with that i think
so if i finish writing the first draft
i like to put it away for a little bit
and try and create a space
where i have like a little bit more
objectivity and then i read it
see if there's anything that i want to
change and if i'm like
no i think i want to show this now then
i'll send it to someone
whose opinion i really value
and have you ever been critical of
something you've written and then you've
given it space and then you go you know
what wow this is actually great
i was too hard on myself or or maybe
vice versa i don't know
i mean i never
i mean all i can really gauge is how
much
i enjoyed writing it and i i tend to
find that the things that i
enjoyed writing more are the ones that i
get better feedback
um about but i think that um
definitely i've i've had treatments
that i've asked notes for and gotten
very like critical notes
like pretty brutal feedback and i've
worried that like oh maybe this is just
really bad and i should scrap
it but then i'm like okay i'm going to
try again
and then i've applied with that same
treatment for
fellowships and like gotten in to those
so it just goes to show that even if
maybe it starts badly that doesn't mean
that it can't
you know end a bit better
you've directed many short films but
this was your first feature
were there like one or two things that
you were totally surprised at
as a first feature film director that
you thought
wouldn't happen or it was just new to
you
because you're doing a longer format i
think
that you know we definitely had some
some things come up that couldn't have
been predicted there were like
there was a weekend that we had to
postpone shooting because there was
a heat wave like a really kind of you
know
terrible heat wave in la at the time
and that's something that it's like
usually usually with a short film
like you know if you shoot for like five
days you're usually you're able to do
those
those five days in a row and if you have
to postpone it's maybe not that big a
deal
but we were lucky that on the feature
that happened more towards the end of
the shoot
because i think if it had happened like
in the beginning or in the middle i
think it would have been really
catastrophic to like um recover
a rhythm and i think that's the most
important thing i think i found that
more in the future than i did on the
short was like how important for there
to be like a rhythm
that's being established and how you
know how you do eventually become a very
well-oiled
machine after like you know two weeks of
working together
so that even when things don't go
according to plan and you do have to
postpone
it's it's okay because when you when you
do
come back together it's you're already
so used to
working with each other that you can
just pick up where you left off
oh wow i hadn't thought of that that's
really interesting
so it takes it takes a few weeks to kind
of get to know
people's styles not just their
personality but their like working
styles
and really like gel together yeah
so then when this heat wave occurred how
many days did that take out of the
production we still had um
two more full days
um and i think a half day that we needed
to do
so even though it was you know i mean it
wasn't great that we had to
to push back and we ended up losing our
dp because he had already booked another
shoot um it could have been worse
yeah did your dad happen to see any of
your films
you know i don't think he did see
any of them but he did because i
actually
started painting when i was like 16 17
18 and i know he really
he liked my paintings but he never
i don't think he ever saw any of my
films
what were you painting i was painting
a lot of female subjects a little like
female form
um but i can't i personally did not
enjoy
painting and i think it was you know
talking to to an art teacher about like
what
i mean do you do you even enjoy the
process of painting or is painting kind
of more like an obstacle for you that
you have to overcome in order to you
know produce this final image that you
have
in your mind and i was like yes it's
it's more the latter it's more that and
he was like
well you might want to consider you know
photography
or or film or video because if you're
not really
interested in painting as a process
if it's more about the image then this
might not be the right medium
for you were you using uh watercolors or
acrylics or
oil well okay wow oil yeah
yeah but i mean i'm pretty sure most
people usually start with like acrylics
and watercolor and they'll like work
their way up to
oil just because it requires i mean
more money because oil paints are not
cheap
um and a lot of technique as well
what do you think he would have thought
of your future film i hope that he would
like
it i hope he would laugh because he
liked to laugh
uh i'd like to i'd like to think that he
would
at the very least find it entertaining
yeah
when your art teacher said that to you
was i'm assuming you approached them and
said that the process was super hard and
and confided in them how did you
take that news was that an insult or
was it in like sort of liberating
because then
you realized maybe this isn't the medium
for you i think it was
i think it was liberating because
it got me excited about something new
you know like the first time you you
know you pick up
like an slr you know and you load the
film and then you're experimenting with
the settings with like
the shutter speed and the aperture and
all of that
and it's and i mean you know developing
your first roll of black and white film
is amazing it feels like a discovery
obviously it's not because people have
been developing black and white film
for you know a very long time now but
when you're a teenager and it's your
first time in a dark room
it's magical like you know you're never
gonna get that
that kind of moment again so it was
definitely very
it was very special once your art
teacher said that
then you picked up the camera and do you
remember what you started shooting
um yeah i mean i remember because i was
i was still
in in lisbon at the time
and i was also i like i spent the summer
in
london and because i was such a big fan
of cindy sherman
like i did a bit of that kind of like
the
you know you know femininity is a
masquerade and kind of experimenting
with like different
looks and what does it mean to be using
your own appropriating your own form as
a woman making
art so that was definitely a big
uh a big influence and then also you
know um
taking pictures in in lisbon which is
such a beautiful
city and kind of like finding like you
know different perspectives
on a place that to me was so familiar
do you ever look back at those photos
now i do
i do i mean and especially for the for
the cindy sherman ones
and i made like great big posters of
those
yeah i know cindy sherman there was a
documentary i think it was done in the
90s and it showed her and
she wanted to talk about her perspective
of being a woman walking down the street
in new york city and these different
things and
did you do anything of that sort of the
the react the
being out in public and maybe
expectation or
um i mean i didn't i mean i didn't do
anything
along those lines
and i but i did like there were a couple
of performance pieces that i
did devise and i thought about doing but
they were more
about like you know manipulating your
own
form and kind of controlling the way
that you are seen by
the viewer so it was less kind of like
that direct
interaction and i mean like you know so
many you know
female artists have have done such you
know amazing work that they've like
directly interacted with with audience
members you know
like um valerie export
yeah and also yoko ono i mean she was a
pioneer
in that way before marina abramovic when
you know no shade
but she was no before um
so no i didn't didn't quite do anything
like like that
but i was aware that the female artists
were doing it yeah
and you said your your mother was also
an artist too no my mother was a french
teacher
oh i'm sorry okay i guess because you
said she enjoyed watching the films oh
okay so
so then how many languages did you speak
growing up
um so portuguese english spanish
and because you know portuguese and
spanish are very similar so it's pretty
easy to learn one if you know
the other uh and also hebrew
oh okay because um because we are
we are of jewish descent german jewish
descent
and also french we didn't really have a
choice we had to speak french because my
mother
mother was like you're gonna have to
learn french wow
so all those different languages and did
you also explore films
from all those different areas for sure
and yeah and different people okay
yeah i'm a big fan of french french
cinema for sure
absolutely and spanish cinema 2 as well
yeah
and so at what point did you even
explore
american cinema it sounds like you had
so many great influences
would you even would you even delve into
that or maybe you did
i i did do a couple like film workshops
in in lisbon when i was in
high school and obviously like one of
the first films that they're going to
show you is citizen kane
like that's sure that's true a staple
right you're not
you're not going to do any course in
like you know film history or film
theory and not watch citizen kane
um so that was probably one of the first
like kind of like classic
um references of american cinema that i
was exposed to
i'm always envious of people that grow
up in europe or different you know
abroad because it seems like they get
such um that they are exposed to many
more worlds it seems like
maybe it's just been a few years since
i've been in school so
it seems like here in the u.s we're not
as exposed to some of that maybe more so
now
but i think you just get so many more
flavors of
and different slices of life i think
that probably really shapes people's
art and their and their outlook and
that's really cool wow it sounds like
you had some really just interesting you
want to talk about uh
we were talking earlier about rodriguez
and saying that it's like making a stew
or you know making some kind of food and
it sounds like you just had all these
different things that you could add
yeah to your palette of ideas
very cool was there an actress somewhat
like marilyn monroe
back in the day in portugal someone that
had this like awe
and mystery around them you know you
talked about you you were interested in
the idea of femininity
and sort of the the perceptions of what
women it had to be
were there any icons i know you talked
about sophia loren and
she was very international but in in
portugal
i mean well she's obviously not of the
same
decades as marilyn monroe but um media
de modages was very
interesting and she was in pulp fiction
right okay so the
the i can't quite remember the name of
her character but she played bruce
willis's
girlfriend right okay that's
who it was portuguese and is an
excellent actress and was just
you know amazing in that film and her
chemistry with bruce willis is
you know impeccable um and she's someone
who
also is not just an actress she also
directs
okay so that's very inspiring to be like
you know a portuguese
a woman who has you know who's you know
started off
acting but now has progressed into being
a filmmaker in her own right
when you were applying for college going
to london
where did you envision you would be a
decade
out did you have an idea of
what you wanted for yourself i mean when
i applied to art school i think
definitely the end goal was to become
you know a professional
artist so that's you know at least back
then that's
that was a different path like you would
maybe be you know
signed to a gallery and then you would
you know apply for residencies you apply
for funding
you would get um and then you would be
able to kind of make your own work and
then that work would be shown in
galleries and then it would go to
museums it would
you know it's that's kind of the
trajectory that i thought i was gonna
have
back then so more as a visual artist
and in terms of i know you said with the
painting that was something that you
sort of abandoned but
you had other you said just more like
video like
sort of ex exhibitions and things like
that so that's kind of where i thought i
was
i was heading wow interesting and then
somehow
just the filmmaking bug it bit you
it took you to la to ucla so one of the
best screenwriting programs and
and and just the energy behind it you
think just kind of
your need to tell stories yes
and also have um to try and have a
sustainable
career because i think
you know definitely it was something
that they said to us
after we graduated from from university
where i was doing
my undergraduate degree was like oh if
you want to if you want to
be taken seriously as an artist if you
really want to consider this as a as a
career you have to do a master's
like you have to you must and and to be
honest
like my my peers who have done well
they did all do a master's degree so
it's it was true and for me like
because i had also done a foundation
degree before doing the four years at
the slate i'd already been like you know
five years in like academic institutions
and i was like
oh no i'm not ready to do a master's
right now
so it was like okay well then what else
can i do
so then you decided to move and you
added you moved to la and you added
so it was a two-year program at ucla it
was i mean usu
in my degree usually people take on
average four years
to to complete the mfa in production
slash directing
and you already completed it and it was
how long
i took three years and a quarter oh okay
would you advise that other either
writers
artists filmmakers any any type of
creative pursuit
always go for a master's degree i mean
it depends i mean there are some
very successful filmmakers who did not
go to film school
and that's that's a fact i don't know if
that's
if it's like 50 50 you know half of the
successful filmmakers in in hollywood
didn't go to film school and the other
half
did i don't i don't know what the
percentages are but i mean i can't say
that
one of the big advantages of going to
film school is is the the community
is the network of like-minded
collaborators that you
will meet but if you have access to that
without having to go
to film school then maybe that's that's
all you need
maybe okay and have you ever seen
someone use that and over rely on that
and not maybe do the work it takes
you know because it sounds like you you
need a combination of both
the the degree the knowing what the
rules are so you can break them and then
just like you said the hustle never
stops or whatever
which that i mean i know i've heard that
but i guess it just sort of
solidified for me today but do you see
people sometimes maybe relying too much
on the fact that they had the degree and
not actually going out there like you
did
and knowing okay i have this opportunity
at this high school i know
a teacher especially who or i'm i'm
sorry i don't even know if he was a
teacher i just
he was he was oh he was okay that that
that
is is simpatico with me and we're we're
doing this
um and but they just they want to be
picked
and you knew that you had to i mean what
what i have seen is like you know um
young filmmakers who have gone through
film schools and they have you know one
short film that does well
that maybe goes to you know the sunni
fundacion which is
which is that can or berlin and they
think
okay now people are going to come to me
i've done enough like i don't need to
keep you know hustling i don't need to
keep
you know making my own connections
making my own contacts working on my own
material like really keeping the engine
going
and the truth is is that in in this day
and age there's so much
competition that i think that if you
don't keep
striving that you will fall behind
and i have seen that happen to some some
filmmakers think that
you know now that i've had a little bit
of success i can just you know
you know cross my arms and like sit back
because it's all going to come to me and
i just
it doesn't really tend to happen that
way so you won't rest on your sundance
success i can't i have to what i have to
do now is um
you know what what any good manager will
tell you is like you have to capitalize
on the buzz
before the buzz dissipates yeah
you